[Musik]
das ist wirklich mal wurde anzeige
gebracht werden
ricco hatte eine holding als alle vorher
vorzugswürdig
[Musik]
alitalia 404 mailand zürich 30 minuten
ein kurzer flug nicht der rede wert
einchecken bordkarte einsteigen die
business class meist besser besetzt als
economy bord routine wie gehabt die
gedanken schon zu hause ein ganz
normaler flug wie er sich täglich x-fach
wiederholt auch am 14 november 1990
scheint noch kurz vor der landung nichts
darauf hinzudeuten dass die tägliche
flug routine in wenigen augenblicken
brutal gestört werden wird
[Musik]
um 20 uhr 13 lokalzeit streift die dc-9
oberhalb des dorfes war die ersten bäume
verliert den rechten flügel dreht sich
nach rechts um die längsachse und bot
sich überschlagend in den bewaldeten
steilhang des stadler werkes die
flughafenfeuerwehr ist in rekordzeit an
der unfallstelle
die rettungsarbeit ist x-fach geübt
alles geht schnell und professionell
aber vergebens 46 passagiere und
besatzungsmitglieder hat nie eine
überlebenschance und die hinterbliebenen
von 46 menschen nie eine chance
abschied zu nehmen
[Musik]
doch
mit der realität schonungsloser
konfrontiert sind die angestellten am
werk am desk ihr beruf ist es fragen zu
beantworten die vielfach mit ungeduld
ärger und unverständnis gepaart sind an
diesem abend weicht die ungeduld der
angst die beiden diensthabenden damen
haben die anweisung in solchen fällen
keine panik aufkommen zu lassen und die
wartenden nach möglichkeit zu beruhigen
ich finde das trusted meter sagt aber
ich spüre dass niemand eine sonnen
energie bezieht die sich wer ist das
ich werde die messe und dame ist vom
stadtrat gruppe hat sich bedankt und die
hd konsolen e netzen
gegen 20 30 fährt frau anderson mit
ihrem sohn jason am terminal a vor wie
schon oft will sie ihren mann abholen
der normalerweise immer zeitungslesen
vor der ankunftshalle steht da nicht zu
sehen ist schickt sie zuerst ihren sohn
hinein der kann seinen vater nirgends
entdecken und cat ratlos zum wagen
zurück daraufhin lässt die mutter den
jungen im auto warten um sich selber zu
erkundigen
und das ist mir vertraut weil ich ja
solange wir das geschafft haben und ich
kenne genau reaktionen wie man so ist
und so und und fragt denn was ist mit
die alitalia wieso hat sich sportlich
und die gesichter sie blieb sehr anders
also ich war irgendwie betroffen ist
durch die ernstlich kite aber macht noch
spaß da was passiert und binden sagt ja
jakl ecke können sie dazu die alitalia
anbinden die rolltreppe hoch also einmal
ist mir von hinter fabi grast und uns
und sagten wir sollen verbiegung
alitalia wäre abgestürzt und den han ich
denke mein gott
denn wenig zu der alitalia chance sich
freuen fräulein ich sage ich habe nie
etwas schlimmes gehört da ist was
passiert ist das war dass die alitalia
abgestürzt ist und die reagiert so
intensiv dass sie mir aus reiz und sagt
von wem herrn sie das gehört ich sage
ich würde gerne mehr wie sonst im auto
wenn das schlimmes ist dann werde ich
das kind doch mit damit konfrontiere
card sagte gysi weiter und wartezeiten
und so bin ich dann im grund realität
dass da wirklich wirklich was nicht
stimmt und dann hat er denkt also wenn
das stimmt dann muss ich sie weg
aufgewühlt wird vollendet und nach hause
denn man müsse einfach passiv abwarte
und erwartet sie war furchtbar weil es
war ja unsicher und sicher bislang
erzielt ich glaube es war denn es da
wurde natürlich hin und her telefoniert
freunde hat wusste bobby suchen
flüge und die hand an glühte und das war
natürlich sehr emotionaler moment
dann habe ich den dfb habe zwölf ganz
offiziell vom fernsehfonds keine
überlebenden
und man hat mich als beruhigungs
medikament so gehe das ist ja ganz klar
aber bis das letzte wort durex ist das
war schon sehr harte und dann hat man
mich ins bett verfrachtet man hat also
der nachbarin hat mit mir hier hat es
wenn man darauf matratze kleid und hat
dann ist er am nächsten morgen hat man
ihm das müsse sagte er ist ja immerhin
hat wo ist denn barbie hat die maschine
verpasst und dann hat man das daneben
müsse sagen das war sie hat ja
das tageslicht des 15 november zeigt die
wunde im nordhang des stadler werkes
trauer und ohnmächtige wut der
hinterbliebenen sind in trümmern
begraben in denen auch antworten auf die
unfallursache verborgen sind
so kommt mit dem schock schon bald die
frage nach der absturzursache
das dem bundesrat direkt unterstellte
büro für flugunfalluntersuchung setzt
eine komplexe untersuchungs maschinerie
in gang
die ersten spuren deuten darauf hin dass
ein terroranschlag ausgeschlossen werden
kann
es macht den anschein als ob die dc-9
kontrolliert in den stadler werk
geflogen sein cockpit voice recorder und
flugdatenschreiber werden gefunden und
zur auswertung nach england gebracht
der datenschreiber im volksmund black
box genannt befindet sich in dieser
gelben box sie ist extrem schlagfest
muss 36 stunden eine meerestiefe von
20.000 fuß und 30 minuten eine
temperatur von 1100 grad celsius
schadlos überstehen können
die flugdaten der alitalia waren wie
hier auf einem magnetstreifen
gespeichert und konnten im gegensatz zum
voice recorder problemlos ausgewertet
werden der ausdruck des schreibers
bestätigt die vermutung dass sich die
dc-9 beim aufprall in normaler landes
stellung gefunden haben muss hier die
konstante sinkt rate aber eben drei bis
vierhundert meter tiefe als gewöhnlich
und hier der exakt auch die pisten achse
ausgerichtete lande kurs interessant ist
dass rund 20 sekunden vor dem aufprall
die flugzeugnase kurz hochgezogen und
wieder gesenkt und gleichzeitig auf
beiden triebwerken schub gegeben und
gleich wieder zurückgenommen wurde
[Musik]
besuch bei familie bürgler
die wohnung ist neu bürglers sind rund
einen monat vor dem flugzeugabsturz bei
dem e mail bürger sein leben verliert
hier eingezogen
den tod der fährt die familie ist der
morgen nach der katastrophe in den
folgenden tagen ist die wohnung das
zentrum großer anteilnahme und
verbundenheit
zehn monate nach diesen bewegenden
zeiten erinnern sich lee berger von der
nähere freunde und einfach alles
bedürfnis k so lange wie möglich bei uns
ziehen mit uns die stunde zu bringen
zum teil einer ganzen echt aber erst mal
gesprochen habe einfach nie zuvor sich
über plötzlich verwacklungen ist wohl
nicht vor der folie im labor montags
prozess hatte von millionen zuschauer 15
bedrohungen und plötzlich ist man derlei
verantwortlich wäre ja alles überhaupt
kein partner märz und darüber sprechen
was kann ich was darf ich was muss ich
machen und jetzt eben ziemlich ob der
tod ist ist für mich als 20 jahre lang
möglich einen extrem heile welt hat also
tot und und schwere krankheit hat sky
was ist im herbst für die auf sie und
glaubt dass das gibt's bei uns nicht und
so etwa essen erfahren und ich bin
obwohl ich eines tages ist und sehr gute
erfahrung will die stelle gegenüber nach
so so heil und unberührt
aber sich wohl in zürich passiert aber
das ist irgendwo mir sind die big 71
nicht miterlebt haben fühlt sich als
nicht sehr sexy und nicht die gabe stand
up cult das erste mal gemerkt dass
erstmal bestätigung eigentlich das foto
links
es ist nicht so zur kabinettssaal bezug
braucht hätte hast du schmutziger
schweizer pass ist leitungen daher
verbringt sie also bis extrem schlimm
das rom eingezogen das ist nur ein tor
schmerz war das ist skifahren
was von der d- c- noch übrig geblieben
ist wird in einer traglufthalle auf dem
flughafen zürich-kloten gesammelt und
dem flugzeug grundriss entsprechend
ausgelegt
für die leute die hier arbeiten dient
der trümmer friedhof der
ursachenforschung
hier laufen anfänglich alle fäden
zusammen von hier aus werden
fortführende ermittlungen in auftrag
gegeben in den räumen des
wissenschaftlichen dienstes der
stadtpolizei zürich wird mit hilfe
neuester technologie nach verräterischen
spuren gesucht die hier arbeitenden
spezialisten genießen weltweit hohes
ansehen und werden noch immer wieder zur
klärung von flugzeugabstürzen beigezogen
mit wissenschaftlicher genauigkeit und
aggressivem spürsinn werden fasern
splitter tröpfchen oder kratzer
akribisch unter die lupe genommen
man sucht nach kalten lötstellen wühlt
in verkohlten kabelkanälen oder ortet
unterbrochene schalter kontakte im falle
der alitalia konzentrierte man sich bei
der ursachenforschung schon bald einmal
auf die navigationsgeräte
nachdem man aber erst einmal
auslegeordnung geschaffen hatte denn
dauert das integrationsplan vor dem
absturz der teilung wundert nummeriert
und so nach vorne
haupt trümmerfeld und seitdem ohne
strafen vorsieht
dazu hat erst beim tor zum 2 und da die
zweite mit dem linken flügel selbst da
im detail zweite triebwerk das
abwesenheit sektor mit dem linken
triebwerk intakt und dazu die wichtigste
sache sind da bleibt der trolle und der
cockpit wollen dass analysebericht ist
sehr wichtig da musste halt im hauptfeld
das am 2 das ist
und so wurde der hsi ein
navigationsgerät des captains im lassen
waldboden gefunden
ein fund von zentraler bedeutung wir
haben versucht nicht instrument
thalys verleiht das tätigkeiten also
vorsicht oberharz 2 die stanzmaschine
kleid werkzeug das sind direkt für die
untersuchung wichtig sie sind bei den
oberhalb des gerätes liegenden distanz
mesz trommeln fanden sich unter dem
mikroskop schleifspuren auf den
einzelnen ziffern
das lässt darauf schließen dass beide
trommeln beim crash in eine
rotationsbewegung waren
was das zu bedeuten hat wird sich noch
im verlaufe der fortschreitenden
untersuchung erweisen
das zentrale augenmerk richtet sich aber
auf die aus dem gerät heraus gelöste
skala der glide weg anzeige unter dem
mikroskop werden kratzspuren sichtbar
die den untersuchungs fortgang
wesentlich beeinflussen werden
die spuren wo man unter dem mikroskop
die hand haben wir da aber noch ab und
zogen aus technisch das ist der
hauptspur komplex wurde zeigt vermutlich
auch schlager hat verdi die erste barbie
ist und dann sind die weitere vorschläge
das heißt bezeichnen darf die ideale
position
sie wurde um power faktisch das flaig wo
wir zeigen dass das instrument nicht
gültig ist unseres erachtens hinter der
maske versteckt sie will mir da absolut
chaotisch burg wunderland jedoch hinter
dem aus die erkenntnisse der zürcher
spurensucher bestätigen die vermutungen
der arbeitsgruppe flugbetrieb die sich
unter anderem mit den vorgängen im
cockpit beschäftigt unter den
verschiedenen szenarien konzentriert man
sich immer mehr auf die möglichkeit
einer falschen glide weg anzeige in
einem dc-9 simulator in großbritannien
werden die instrumente entsprechend
präpariert
aufgrund der daten von flugschreiber
radaraufzeichnungen und cockpit voice
recorder kann der flug von alitalia 404
genau nachvollzogen werden wo man
besonders geht es gar nicht
und siehe da es wunderbar funktioniert
mit jeder anflug mehrmals gelogen
mit dem simulator hier mit dem autopilot
vom 7 und das ist gerne auf gekommen um
zu sehen was da genau aufgegangen ist
fliegen wir für eine instrumentenflug
landung bei tageslicht die piste 14 an
an diesem punkt haben wir eine höhe von
circa 4.000 fuß und können stadler berg
und piste gut erkennen
für eine instrumenten landung braucht es
nun zwei sender einer der in der
verlängerten pisten achse sendet der
sogenannte locker leiser und einer der
vom pisten anfang aus in einem winkel
von drei grad schräg nach oben strahlt
der sogenannte gleitflug die schnitt
linie der beiden sender ergibt den glide
weg der zur pisten schwelle führt die
pisten achse befindet sich etwas links
von unserem standort das zeigt auf
unserem instrument auch die nach links
versetzte gelbe nadel an
sie wandert in die mitte wenn wir auf
dem locker leiser also auf der
verlängerten pisten achse sind hier ist
der glide weg noch über uns deshalb ist
die rote kleid weg nadel auch noch im
oberen bereich der skala geradeaus
weiter geflogen treffen wir dann auf den
gleich weg wenn auch die rote nadel
genau damit folglich die piste genau im
fadenkreuz ist auf unserem instrument
lesen wir die entfernung von der piste
ab acht meilen
hier sind wir nun acht meilen von der
pisten schwelle entfernt dort wo sich
die alitalia am 14 november kurz nach 20
uhr gefunden hat es ist stockdunkle
nacht aber die pisten beleuchtung ist
klar zu erkennen dass
navigationsinstrument zeigt locker
leiser und gleich lob zentriert die
maschine sollte sich also auf dem kleid
weg befinden
tatsächlich befinden wir uns in der
verlängerten pisten achse aber der glide
weg liegt mehr als 1000 fuß über uns die
anzeige ist also falsch
und wenn die sim-karte konstant
beibehalten wird fliegt der autopilot
die maschine unweigerlich in den stadler
berg
während die technische bewältigung des
unfallgeschehens voranschreitet die
medien sich wieder anderen ereignissen
zu wenden kommt auch für maria bürgler
der alltag langsam wieder ins
bewusstsein
ein alltag den man sich erst mal
erarbeiten muss den wochenendsitz will
sie zuerst spontan verkaufen doch
nachbarliche anteilnahme im camp vermag
sie wieder umzustimmen aber nicht immer
und überall sind freunde darum
schützende unterstützung zu gewähren
total habe ich immer ein paar mit
tochter oder sohn und daniel es kommt
einfach wieder so dass man sich widerruf
hauptplatz und und sag's ihnen jetzt
muss der staat jetzt bitter wenn man
glück hat dass man immer trifft man am
anfang richtig froh man hat ja im
prinzip ja selber angst vor der
konfrontation aber dann wo ich merke ich
bin einfach einmal heiko war ich allein
bin ist meine tochter da und dort dieses
ganz alleingang und da nicht einfach
sagt ich habe das gefühl ich bin 60 als
wir wenn die leute mich werdet einfach
mal da und da hat es bei mir einfach auf
danke so so kann es nicht weiter auch
weil ich bin ein spontaner teppich ich
wollte mit qualität und das war nicht
einfach nicht vertragen und danach ich
mich einfach antritt und und dann hat
man im ersten wahlgang waren ich auf sie
zugegangen sind
und wären damit reagiert eigentlich dann
ganz normal ganz normal sie haben mich
fragen ist mir persönlich und wir sonst
das muss dann ist der bann gebrochen sie
effektiv der jason hat mich aus dem
schwarzen hose weil meine kräfte sind
wachse und ich bin sehr aktiven frau
also ich sehr gerne also mit der hand
greift die haben immer gleich gehen dass
gott wieder mit mit dem pinsel und hat
sie mir was sie malen oder zu
restaurieren
irgendwas und wie ich denn die
schockzustand erleben musste war alles
weg ich habe nur noch eigentlich renault
sitzen
unterdessen hat das beobachtet zins und
dann konso 7 einsatz mami ich wollte
noch nicht sterben dann denke ich mir ja
natürlich nicht also da ist
sie sind du musst ja noch nicht sterben
wieso dann sagt er ja mama aber wenn du
jetzt stirbt was mache ich denn da so er
beobachtet also die die mutter von mir
dabei benehmen so sichert ob die das wo
alles so schafft das hat mich
wachgerüttelt daran ich wusste also wenn
schon denn schon
das rind hat zurecht auf dem level und
ich bin verantwortlich
also da muss ich jetzt doch diese wir
haben will dafür jason wiederin lachen
mutter sie außergewöhnliches und einfach
dass er merkt dass liebe gott trotzdem
weiter
[Musik]
die unfalluntersuchung konzentriert sich
in der folge auf die navigationsgeräte
die technischen unterlagen der dc-9
ergeben dass nach der rückkehr aus
frankfurt und vor dem flug nach zürich
in mailand beide navigations empfänger
wegen kleiner funktionsfehler
ausgewechselt worden sind wir haben hier
das auswechseln eines solchen empfängers
nachgestellt wie unser gerät hier kamen
beide empfänger aus dem ersatzteillager
und wurden von zwei alitalia mechanikern
in den bauch der dc-9 eingebaut
es liegen keine konkreten anhaltspunkte
vor dass das auswechseln der geräte
nicht korrekt durchgeführt worden wäre
es gibt auch keine hinweise dass der
eine empfänger schon defekt aus dem
lager kam zum vorgeschriebenen
auswechslung verfahren gehört auch ein
funktionstest mit einem knopfdruck wird
ein internes testsignal erzeugt und der
locker leiser und laiz lob empfänger
können so künstlich überprüft werden
der mechaniker muss dabei den
testverlauf auf dem entsprechenden
instrument im cockpit überwachen
es gibt auch hier keine anhaltspunkte
für ein fehlverhalten der beiden
alitalia angestellten nach dem test
wurde die maschine zudem den
vorschriften entsprechend für ein
anflugverfahren frei gegeben bei dem
beide navigationsgeräte gleichzeitig
benutzt werden müssen
tatsache ist dass durch den hohen
zerstörungsgrad des empfängers nicht
mehr festgestellt werden kann wo wann
und wie der verhängnisvolle defekt
entstanden ist es genügt nicht
was die fahrzeuge also das heißt es ist
nicht ein genügender faktor
das ist ein sehr großer mitwirkung der
faktor wenn bis anhin die meinung
vorherrschte die falsche gleis lob
anzeige sei ein bisher unbekanntes
phänomen zu belegen nun plötzlich
auftauchende dokumente dass dieser
mangel schon lange bekannt war 1975
machte der gerätehersteller collins auf
ebendiese fehlanzeige aufmerksam und dem
fall nachdrücklich den umbau der geräte
alitalia befolgte diese empfehlung nicht
1984 dann ein schreiben des
flugzeugherstellers dallas allerdings
nur in form eines briefes an seine
kunden und nicht mit einer mitteilung an
die luftaufsichtsbehörde die artist
briefes hat zudem die alitalia
möglicherweise auf das problem zu wenig
aufmerksam gemacht dass unglücks gerät
das im brief ebenfalls erwähnten
herstellers king wurde zu jenem
zeitpunkt nur in flugzeugen der alitalia
tochtergesellschaft ati eingesetzt und
gelangte erst 1989 durch flugzeug
übernahme in die maschinen der alitalia
eine weitere chance die sache zu
bereinigen wird sich nochmals im jahre
1985 also dass ein seminar zu dieser
problematik veranstaltete an dem sowohl
piloten der alitalia wie auch der ati
teilnahmen
trotz all dieser briefe und
veranstaltungen hatten die beiden
piloten der unglücks dece 9
die kenntnis über mögliche fehlern
zeigen ihre navigationsgeräte
betriebe vor der flugzeuge dann vollends
alitalia verdammt wusste japan
verzichtet das apple bietet sky will
meine ksc verfahren der frische
verfahren das problem bereits abdeckt
am stadler berg wächst langsam gras über
die absturz wunde oberhalb des kreuzes
dort wo der hang etwas flacher wird
stehen seit dem frühling drei
kirschbäume gepflanzt auf initiative von
familie bürgler
diese symbolische handlung bringt
verschiedene angehörige gemeinsam zum
stadler berg und das ist immer das
schwierigste jahr natürlich man sich ja
bekanntlich nur hört mir ist das
register mache kann ich leben passiert
weiter und und trotzdem sage ich noch
einen schönen tag wurde womit die bäume
pflanzt hand als symbolischen akt einig
sind dann aber und soll sich dann die
erste kontakte ich trage entstand im
märz haben können
so glaubt alle beteiligten bringen
brooks control zürich-kloten die
flugverkehrsleiter überwachen und lenken
hier mit hilfe ihres radar bildes die
flugzeuge im nahbereich des flughafens
sie stehen dabei mit den piloten im
funkkontakt und müssen gleichzeitig die
flugbewegungen mit anderen lotsen an
anderen arbeitsplätzen koordinieren
am abend des 14 november 1990 sind hier
kurz nach 20 uhr ordnungsgemäß zwei
arbeitsplätze im betrieb einer für
abfliegende und einer für ankommende
maschinen seit etwa einer viertelstunde
hat der lotse im anflug bereich reibel
genannt viel zu tun
es war der übliche verkehr zu bewältigen
die um diese zeit immer relativ komplex
ist rund fünf minuten vor dem unfall
liegen die finnair 63 alitalia vor zero
vor der businessjet rabbit meint rita
lufthansa uniform und das schul flugzeug
reisen at one two im
verantwortungsbereich des controllers
dessen kunst ist es die maschinen in der
eben genannten reihenfolge in möglichst
kurzen abständen auf den strich das
heißt die verlängerte pisten achse und
damit auf das instrumentenlandesystem zu
führen
er weist ihnen dazu entsprechende
flughöhen kurs richtungen und
geschwindigkeiten zu der
flugverkehrsleiter betätigt sich hier
hauptsächlich als verkehrsfluss manager
das heißt möglichst viele flugzeuge in
möglichst kurzer zeit ohne
warteschleifen auf den boden zu bringen
eine folge des immer dichter werdenden
luftverkehrs die gleichzeitige führung
von drei verkehrs einem leicht und einem
langsamen propellerflugzeug stellt hohe
anforderungen an die aufrechterhaltung
der vorgeschriebenen unterschiedlichen
mindestabstände computerunterstützung
ist hier erst in planung an
informationen stehen dem lotsen auf dem
radarschirm neben der position der
maschine noch die geschwindigkeit und
die höhe zur verfügung die zahl 051
unter az a 404 gibt die höhe
5100 fuß die zahl rechts daneben
24 die geschwindigkeit also 240 knoten
an der flugverkehrsleiter sieht bei
einer anflug sequenz das gesamtbild der
sich fortbewegen flugzeuge und nicht die
einzelnen zahlenwerte wenn vor dem
eindringen auf die pisten achse die
einhaltung der zugewiesenen höhe noch
bewusst kontrolliert wird so achte der
lotse beim entern flug in erster linie
auf die abstände
zumal die piloten wenn sie auf dem
gleitet appelliert sind für die
korrektheit des landeanflugs selbst
verantwortlich sind die längst auf dem
strich muss vom optischen eindruck her
stimmung in der fülle der informationen
fallen einzelne zahlen nicht auf wenn
man nicht speziell darauf achtet und die
alitalia war optisch gesehen immer am
richtigen ort
die abstände stimmten und im funkkontakt
mit dem piloten war nie eine spur von
unsicherheit zu erkennen gewesen was die
aufmerksamkeit des lotsen automatisch
erhöht hätte der flugverkehrsleiter hat
immer das gesamte radarbild vor sich wie
hingegen können nun nachträglich im
wissen um das unfallgeschehen unsere
aufmerksamkeit mit hilfe der kamera
bewusst auf die alitalia daten richten
wir sehen dass die maschine ständig
absinkt anstatt noch weitere drei meilen
auf 4000 fuß zu bleiben
keine antwort von finnair rabbit mein
trikot wird für den landeanflug
freigegeben
alles scheint am richtigen ort zeit um
mit dem zweiten flugverkehrsleiter die
abflug sequenz einer startenden maschine
koordinieren zu können
nun meldet sich die fan er doch noch
jetzt macht die luft der funkkontakt
wird gestört so dass die aufforderung
zum absenken und geschwindigkeit
reduzieren wiederholt werden muss
[Applaus]
das optische bild stimmt aber nach wie
vor die horizon kann jetzt zum strich
geführt werden während die alitalia im
richtigen abstand zur finger auf die
tonfrequenz verwiesen wird auf der
beinahe gleichen höhe wie die finger
das verschwinden des radar signals der
alitalia wird mit ungläubigem staunen
registriert die controller versuchen
herauszufinden was passiert ist
alitalia 404 wird mehrmals erfolglos
aufgerufen
schließlich die anfrage an red nein
ob sie etwa zwei meilen vor sich ein
anderes flugzeug hätten die antwort löst
den großalarm aus
[Musik]
also der flugverkehrsleiter falls ja wie
sika mit zum beispiel die höhe zu
erteilen wurden aus prima sache
die bezeichnet werden wir müssen
feststellen dass sich bereits jetzt für
die flugsicherheit dass sich akhavan ich
hoffe dass das flugzeug unkontrolliert
absicht das zurückfinden ins
alltagsleben heißt für frau anderson
auch rückkehr in die arbeitswelt für sie
ist dieser schritt besonders schwierig
denn ihr letzter arbeitsort war der
flughafen ein ort an dem sie gern
gearbeitet hat ein ort an dem sie
schließlich wieder zurückkehrt um im
dienstleistungsbereich tätig zu sein
keine einfache rückkehr hat auch
veränderten auf dem flughafen seinerzeit
ihren mann kennengelernt
und da sind so viele ringe verwundern
der nachahmer
ich krieg auf die seite von der halle
krieges ja-wort und grad gegenüber ist
alitalia schaute und daher nicht
erfahren und das sind zwei so alles
eigentlich da aber das war anne will
dadurch besser dass man dadurch hund und
ich meine jetzt verkauft ich das einfach
dass man darf auf das ist henrik und das
ist die henrik am anfang weiß ich noch
kurz wie ich beide flügel gestanden bin
dann haben wir das machen
also man sieht ja immer genauso auf wege
vorfahren war seht ihr person sehr lang
noch oder stau und dass das eben sind
momente das muss man buchstäblich muss
man das mit mit dem hirn sagte es ist
nicht möglich ist ist vorbei und zurück
annäherung an den flughafen auch bei
familie bürgler tochter claudia meinen
griechenland in den ferien und wird
jetzt von mutter und bruder abgeholt
im hintergrund einfach krampf zusammen
wie ist das gerät oft arbeitet sie
wieder zu trainieren und wieder
verprügelt ich kann sie nicht zurück
hand und es ist klar zum laufen musste
keller und ich werde jeden mann arbeitet
auch große gegangen ist und sowohl
science monitor sie aber ich glaube bei
uns sitzt so tief dass man abflug gehen
und lehrt als jetzt zeigen
es kommt einem frieden mit druck
nur jetzt diese später an passenden
teile seiner ganzen hand gelassen
aber das wort landing ist für mich schon
jetzt wieder positiven bewegung
der cockpit voice recorder wurde fast
gleichzeitig mit dem flugdatenschreiber
gefunden
die auswertung dauert aber erheblich
länger da die position des mikrofons im
cockpit viele gesprächs teile schwer
verständlich machte
zudem behielten sich die piloten
größtenteils in italienischen dialekt
und verschiedene arbeitsabläufe konnten
nur anhand von geräuschen analysiert
werden aufgrund dieser aufnahmen kann
man aber feststellen dass beide piloten
voll bei der sache zu sein schienen und
die gespräche im cockpit sich nur um
fliegerische belange treten
der captain zeigte dabei seine
erfahrungs bedingte überlegenheit und
ließ den co piloten auch spüren es
herrschte ein eigentliches lehrer
schüler verhältnis der co-pilot schien
zumindest äußerlich die schüler rolle zu
akzeptieren zumal er längere zeit die
falsche anflug hatte vor sich hatte
was den captain zu gönnerhaft im tadel
veranlasste das partnerschaftliche
teamwork ein sicherheitsnetz in der
fliegerei existierte nicht der co pilot
wurde in eine passive rolle gedrängt und
war nicht in der lage seine eigentliche
funktion als fliegender pilot auszuüben
in diesem simulator haben wir aufgrund
aller erkenntnisse die letzten fünf
minuten des unglücksfluges noch einmal
nachgestellt
[Musik]
von 1000 interessenten
die dc-9 wird für die landung
vorbereitet höhenmesser dem aktuellen
luftdruck anpassen lande konfiguration
setzen durch startverfahren ansprechen
schon vorher abgesprochen ist ein
sogenannter kategorie 2 an flug weil er
auf veranlassung der mechaniker in
mailand beide navigations empfänger
überprüft werden mussten
die briefings der beiden piloten sind
unvollständig die publizierten check
verfahren der alitalia werden nicht
eingehalten
die besatzung agiert ausgehend vom
captain mit routinierter lässigkeit
[Musik]
möglicherweise werden bei einem kurzen
blick aus dem cockpit die pisten lichter
registriert alles scheint richtig zu
laufen
die selbstbewusste haltung des captains
auf dem linken sitz spürt man auch beim
funk sprech verkehr mit dem fluglotsen
der co-pilot dagegen zeigt
unsicherheiten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nein
beliebter dämpfen was ihr vor das buch
[Musik]
chili durchgeleitet
zum 1
schiller
[Musik]
bin ich sing along the mission radio
in diesem moment hat die katastrophe
schon angefangen
um das zu analysieren halten wir den
flug an kurz vor dem erreichen der
verlängerten pisten achse schaltet der
captain offen
damit sind beide navigationsgeräte auf
den empfang der beiden sender für pisten
richtung und glide weg geschaltet mit
der frage hast du denn kleid wird klar
dass nicht beide dieselbe begleitweg
anzeige haben die des captains ist
zentriert beim co piloten ist der zeiger
noch gar nicht sichtbar
beide geräte sind ohne warnt flagge die
dc-9 befindet sich zu diesem zeitpunkt
ca 1500 fuß unter dem kleid weg das
navigationsgerät nummer zwei des
kopiloten zeigt also richtig an
mit dem ausspruch des captains machen
wir es auf 1 bestimmte er seine anzeige
ohne präzise analyse als die richtige
und mit dem umschalten auf position eins
werden nun alle navigationsinstrumente
nur noch vom gerät nummer eins versorgt
sämtliche glide weg anzeigen sind nun
zentriert und der autopilot fliegt die
maschine nach diesen angaben so wie wenn
sie sich auf dem effektiven glide weg
befinden würde von einem kategorie 2 an
flug keine rede mehr
die crew scheint sich keinerlei gefahr
bewusst
[Musik]
reduzieren sich sehr
catalog get right but catcher für diese
tour als postalia
ich selbst sehr
es ist sein
[Musik]
ein cello ist
das fahrwerk wird ausgefahren
rund 11 meilen von pisten anfang
entfernt exakt auf der verlängerten
pisten achse aber mehr als 1.200 fuß zu
tief der captain zum co-piloten kommt
die katastrophe wirklich unausweichlich
mit einem quervergleich auf andere
instrumente hätte man sie erkannt 11
meilen von der piste entfernt zeigt der
höhenmesser eine höhe von 2300 fuß an
auf der anflug karte die jeder pilot
neben sich hat darf bis acht meilen vor
der piste die höhe von rund 2600 fuß
nicht unterschritten werden
[Musik]
selbst wenn die perspektive
zettel automatischen qualität jeden
clips 50 mit jammer
[Musik]
treffen dort quasi familie
nur ein passat o
nun etwas kulanter marke nur noch an die
alte
b
[Musik]
auch jetzt wäre nochmals gelegenheit die
katastrophe abzuwenden
der captain nennt die höhe auf der das
radiosignal des sogenannten automakers
durchflogen werden muss 1250 fuß beinahe
vier meilen von der piste entfernt mit
der schüchternen frage haben wir den
autor wacker schon passiert gibt der
co-pilot zu verstehen dass da etwas
nicht stimmen kann
denn der höhenmesser zeigt ihm dass die
marke höhe bereits unterschritten ist
der captain verneint hat jetzt aber
wegen der entfernung von sieben meilen
erste zweifel
mitten in diese zweifel kommt die
aufforderung des controllers auf die
turm frequenz zu wechseln
das mag die bedenken möglicherweise
wieder etwas zerstreut das gefühl der
sicherheit eine scheinsicherheit wieder
verstärkt habe
renault mid
[Musik]
die letzten 25 sekunden sind geprägt von
zunehmender unsicherheit was beiden
keinen sinn machte waren vermutlich die
rotierenden trommel der
entfernungsmesser der höhenmesser zeigt
300 fuß über grund der captain fordert
den kopiloten aufzuziehen dieser
schaltet den autopiloten aus gibt gas
und will durchstarten was
erwiesenermaßen die dc-9 noch gerettet
hätte
dass der captain den durch start-up
recht kann nur mit dem viel ablesen des
höhenmessers erklärt werden anstatt 300
1.300 fuß verschiedene unfallberichte
weisen seit langem auf die gefahr des
falschen ablesen
bei diesen veralteten höhenmetern hin
deshalb ist in unserem simulator noch
ein zweiter modernerer höhenmesser
eingebaut
ein solches flugzeug hoppe forderte
strikte die vorgeschriebene verfahren
dem operiere vor dem flugzeug und sinne
sie stehen
es ist ein schwieriger zum operieren als
andere klubs
es ist nicht schwierig aber sie stehen
vor dem flugzeug und für fahrer warnt
etwa der alitalia forderte strikte für
große disziplin
die hat nicht das als trick funktioniert
einfach hätte den fall nicht strikt der
funktioniert so etwas gar nicht so
falsch
technische und menschliche fehler
leichter sind offenbar zu machen
das ist verknüpft vor faktor auslastung
technisches problem und nachher durch
operationelle fahrleistungen vor dem 20
nicht gerettet wenn man so will beginnt
die katastrophe mit der herstellung des
navigationsgerätes über dessen
fehlfunktion man beim flugzeughersteller
und bei der alitalia kenntnis hatte
davon wusste aber die besatzung nichts
die zudem durch fehlendes teamwork und
unfachmännisch das verhalten nicht in
der lage war die fehlfunktion zu
erkennen
die fragwürdige auslegung der schaltung
der navigationsinstrumente und ein
höhenmesser der als sogenannter kierling
auto metro bekannt ist haben das
fehlverhalten der piloten mit begünstigt
und am schluss blieb auch noch auf den
radarschirmen die falsche höhe der dc-9
beim flugverkehrsleiter unbemerkt das
zeigt dass technik allein von
etablierten dem wunschzettel der
hersteller sie die thematik sitz an bord
und sechs der frauen im cockpit element
und ein stern reporter macht diesen
trick durch die fahrer treten
der gemeinsame gang zum berg ist für die
hinterbliebenen in der zwischenzeit zur
tradition geworden so idyllisch um
friedlich diese bilder auch sein mögen
das geschehen ist noch lange nicht
verarbeitet die trauer noch nicht zu
ende
das anfänglich gespannte verhältnis zu
alitalia auf der menschlichen ebene hat
sich zwar gebessert
missverständnisse wurden ausgeräumt aber
die juristische bewältigung der
katastrophe für den seelischen
verarbeitungsprozess wohl noch um einige
zeit hinauszögern
die bisher ausgezahlten
sonderziehungsrechte kompensieren in den
wenigsten fällen das langfristige
einkommen da unfallopfer weitergehende
entschädigungsforderungen und damit auch
die suche nach den schuldigen werden
wohl unausweichlich vor dem richter
enden müssen
der gang zum berg dürfte sich wohl noch
viele male wiederholen ist die
geschichte auch juristisch bewältigt
sein wird
[Musik]